o lado pessoal aqui quem fala é o dar
que seja muito bem vindo é mais um vídeo
e não estraga um vídeo há tanto tempo
porque meu processo durante um eventual
ataque ainda hoje temos equipes o ao
luau permite nelsi das fêmeas
hoje não estou marcha olá doutora hoje o
seu paciente é o kevin incluirá deu
matou a irmã não a curiosidade deu meteu
em apuros parece ter engolido qualquer
coisa perigosa para silva a nossa função
é conseguir tirá-lo do estômago
espero que não seja que eu pensar porque
se chegou até o estômago
temos de tirar um raio x da barriga do
paciente por vermos um deve ser feita a
incisão primeiro nova cruz vermelha por
um local assinalado com um x vera cruz
vermelha é esta o meu melhor
michael jackson absurdo porque não
conseguimos a equipe para lá temos que
acertar no alvo quem cima do umbigo quem
xingou chaves mil quem vai cair para
segurar a respiração estável do paciente
temos de entrar primeiro gol em tubarão
nós vamos ter um tubo na boca do rapaz
corretamente temos de limpar a garganta
ou gata olga pega no larry jorge está na
mesa laringe pop rock é isto pode não é
um homem justo op - estão machado meu
nós vamos arrancar a língua do rapaz
pega no tubo endotraqueal lula que está
na mesa twin dutra que a ferroeste boca
agora vamos introduzir na garganta do
paciente
eu sei quem consiga aguentar com isto lá
dentro mesmo a gestão é páscoa tem
praias do sado não quero
o trabalho agora pode se mover ou da
garganta
agora vamos ligar o turbo em mogi dutra
em outubro
louro watch peru vou esperar para dentro
dos pulmões
antes de iniciar uma pressão temos de
estabilizar a barriga do paciente para
isso vamos utilizar a pinça e uma paula
aguda' um usa pensa para pegar na bola
de algodão bolinha algodão ano a uma
desfavor de algodão na solução de metade
não é verdade isso é super camarão e
aplique na barriga do paciente no lago
o trabalho agora podemos iniciar a
pressão vamos começar por fazer uma
incisão na barriga do paciente
o primeiro pega no marcador que está na
mesa
falei agora elas tiverem comer alguma
coisa muito isto a veja um vídeo depois
porque está agora vai ver saga pega no
bisturi faz a primeira decisão pode ou
não isso não faz assim tanta pressão
está apenas um corte pequeno é algumas
vaias começaram os 100 gramas não é
preocupante por isso não há estresse
martins foi menos o que chama pega num
catalisador para cauterizar e isaías
sangrar cauterizadora que está
proprietário e não é isso quem mais
vezes para fechar de parar a hemorragia
os músculos precisamos de grampos para
isso por isso pega nos que estão na mesa
e branco está aqui os grandes é isto
esta parte que nós vamos afastar apurava
pellman agora fora precisamos de outro
conjunto de grandes para afastar o
fígado pega nos grampos que estão na
mesa nós vamos apurar o estômago mas não
vamos afastaram fica por cima papel dos
pulmões ou nunca imaginei como a pressão
ao sistema que fosse assim eu tivesse
que apostar um fígado vamos introduzir
uma câmera para vermos o que está
acontecendo no estômago do paciente pega
na câmara que está na mesa câmera go pro
ataque vai falar com o próprio
agora podemos ver o que está acontecendo
no interior não podemos porque está
apagado um decreto está a chave é
encontrar encontrar vamos promover esta
porcaria pega na pinça tá na mesa rápido
em dois minutos e quarenta de capins
ataque pinça
agora vamos remover todos os
instrumentos do corpo do paciente
estruturar decisões vamos começar pelo
estômago
cansado pode desligar o ventilador agora
eu vou morrer com falta dar meu muito
bem agora um novo tubo em do treino
obrigado doutor é cada deus não parece
uma grandíssima é então é isso só vamos
ficar por aqui e espero que vocês tenham
gostado deste vídeo aqui do meu lado
esquerdo vocês vão ter mais dois vídeos
da operação explicaram muito bacana e
por isso passei por lá deixa o nosso
apoio vai cumprir no espírito também não
é porque é importante se for em novos
vídeos vencedores e que o canal dar pra
mim faz um subsedes lanús pride spartans
fique bem e até a próxima eu